thank you for joining us
um for the black hair conversation
alongside
glamour and aveda in association with
flat skin directory
i'm dji dele and i am the founder of
black skin directory
but that side we're not here about that
we're here about the black hair
conversation
and just before we proceed into you know
having a good talk about you know the
facts and
and the real deal about black black hair
and afroeh i just wanted to take a
moment
to introduce everyone on the panel
because everyone here is seriously
accomplished and i think we should all
celebrate that
so first up we have rene garda and she
is evaders global artistic director for
texture
and she has been in the game and
passionate about hair from a very very
young age
and renee does strive to educate others
about the fascinating range
and depth of all hair textures and in
her role particularly evader
she leads a team of five talented
texture artists
in the veda network who advise the brand
on product innovation
facilitate corporate education and lead
the training
of the updated texture curriculum at
aveda's 64 partner
institute locations and so she is a busy
busy woman and she does that globally
so thank you renee for giving up your
time this evening
um we also have jamilia donaldson who is
the founder and ceo of treasure chest
which is europe's largest monthly
discovery subscription box for women
with kinky curly hair
delivering hair care packages to over 26
26 countries monthly
and also jamilia is the co-creator of
the teen experience
which is a series of personal
development workshops series for eight
for teen girls
since launching in 2015 with a huge
online community and an active and
thriving offline presence as well
treasure chest has proven that natural
hair beauty
sisterhood and community going hand in
hand and i am here for it so thank you
so much
emilia last but not least we have
eleanor richardson
who is a consultant psychologist at the
fulham scalp and hair clinic
she diagnoses hair and scalp conditions
with a particular emphasis on the
treatment
of afro and mixed hair and scalp
conditions
eleanor studied at the institute of
psychologist and
qualified as a member in 2015 and she is
a
fully paid up qualified top level
psychologist because i know there's two
different levels so
she regularly provides educational
seminars and lectures on tackling hair
bias
which is a lot of healthy hair care
practice and also dealing with hair loss
so thank you so much ladies it's a
pleasure to have you here this evening
thank you thank you so much for the
introductions yeah
pleasure so we're going to go straight
in because we do have quite a few
questions
so um and i'm going to drag the first
question at you eleanor actually
um what sort of conditions do
trichologists
treat and when should one start
looking to see a trichologist yeah of
course
so i think the most common things that
people associate with trichologists is
hair loss
you know hair shedding drop in density
and patches
and certainly we do treat all those
things um or we can help to diagnose and
figure out what's going on and give you
an explanation
but also we treat loads of other things
like
flaky scalps itchy scalps if you've
noticed that
your hands always in your scalp and it's
picking up things you know it doesn't
sound particularly pleasant but
it also needs to have some expert advice
to understand what's going on
um so things like eczema's psoriasis
even acne on the scalp we treat and then
we've got another um kind of group of
customers who
also come and see us because they
actually want really clear
specialized expert advice on exactly how
to care for their hair what is a good
routine
rather than trial and error with
products over and over again
so it's um it's my pleasure to you know
give them some guidance get their
questions answered
and then steered them in the right
direction for them
fantastic so taking on from you know
trial and error and trying loads of
products i mean
we have treasure chest which is a which
is curated
um so that people can try very good
quality products
um to to be able to know what works for
them so
leading straight into jamilia so
how do you curate a box that people are
able to learn from how do you
select the products so that people are
able to to get the best out of it
so we work in a few different ways as a
team
we're eight women all got natural hair
but completely different hair types
so sometimes we're recommending our
personal favorites
other times we're working with our
favorite brands to celebrate and launch
and to help them launch
but otherwise there is a typical formula
that we stick to for our boxes
um so it should contain a cleanser a
deep conditioner or mask a leave-in
conditioner
an oil or a steiner so that's our
typical box and every now and then we do
do like a styling box or a conditioning
box
but typically speaking treasure chest
boxes are meant to deliver your wash day
so everything that you need
to take care of your hair for that month
you're going to try it um and as far as
the brand as i mentioned it's a range of
different brands
personal favorites um new launches
exclusive launches
sometimes even pre-launches before they
hit the uk market as well
so a few different ways so it's actually
very very interesting to hear
how what happens you know it's not just
random it's actually very very well
considered
which is i guess this is what the afro
hair market needs a well considered
selection
of products to help look after hair
health which then leads me nicely on
straight to renee
um you know we we talk about um
we have a focus on on the length of hair
and on the ends of our hair
but you know as as someone who deals
with different types of textures all the
time
you know you you've got all that in the
bag but how how do we
um how do we maintain healthy hair
scalp and follicles you know because a
lot of the time
people might have long hair but their
scalp itself it's not doing the thing we
want it to do
so you know they have long hair but it's
like okay it's not even healthy so how
do we
how do we look at that yeah i mean i
believe healthy
scalp healthy hair if your scalp is
doing well and thriving the
it'll show up in the rest of your hair
um and just the way that i teach my
clients about their hair and the way i
teach hairdressers about hair is that
you have to treat them as different
entities
the hair that's closest to the scalp
that has all of your nutrients and the
things that you need
and the hair that's been with you for a
while mid shaft to ends
and so taking care of those things like
they're separate things
um is important like caring for your
scalp
and your roots and then doing something
usually
deeper conditioners or adding more oils
to the midshaft and ends throughout
or in between wash days um and then
even on cleanse days making sure that
you give particular attention
to the mitch after ends um for
for black women usually it's like the
mid shaft to ends has
similar concerns to what the roots has
too and so
but for for different textures uh like
looser textures like wavy or curly
uh those mid shaft to ends are they're
they can be a different
a different beast so really what you're
saying is that
you know you have to kind of almost look
at your hair in sections
so the scalp is almost a different
section
to the mid and then you have the ends so
almost like three sections if you want
to look it in
in that way in and tailor your
your hair care towards that fantastic
so in in that case eleanor
um when we talk about um
damage how do things like hair follicles
um how do they become damaged what sort
of practices are people
perhaps doing or not doing that causes
damage to follicles
so i think the most common damage that
we end up seeing in the clinic
is traction so that's like a pulling
force
that's been applied um because of a very
tight style maybe it's
you know very chunky braids or
extensions
or weave-in style that's been there for
a while as well
um and we i guess the easiest way to
think about it is
you know one follicle has kind of been
designed by your body to cope with the
weight of one hair
so the moment we put extra hair on that
one follicle it's like struggling
straight away
um and we see that eventually causing
longer term damage sometimes even
scarring if it's been
you know not treated um the same styles
are being used again and again and again
and then the other kind of damage that
we can see on follicles is
usually around infection of the scalp so
infrequent cleansing or maybe you're
prone to acne but you're not
managing the acne very well scratching
picking spots
allowing bacterial infection to spread
um
any infection of any skin you're gonna
see it it causes inflammation it causes
a struggle
it's the same on your scalp and like
we've already said
unhealthy scalp you're not going to get
the best growing hair as a result so we
always want to deal with that
and limit the damage as much as possible
fantastic
so we've got just had a question um come
in actually in in relation to
sort of hair and scalp especially in
relation to the season we're in which
we're going into winter very quickly
so question from michelle what are the
key elements to maintain
moisture in the natural hair especially
in the winter months i'm gonna
actually ask all of you to give your
take on that because i'm sure there
might be some gems in there from each of
you
so let's go with um i'll stick i'll
stick with you actually eleanor you go
fast and then we'll move on to renee and
jamilia as well
so for me it's all about hydration and i
think
that commonly gets confused sometimes
with um oils
um so when i talk about hydration i'm
talking about water content
and products that can offer that water
content or
my personal favorite is a good steam
treatment i love a steam treatment
get some the water in there but also it
works really well makes your products
work really hard
so when it comes to the winter months if
you notice that you know
the uh the heating's on a bit more maybe
you're wearing more woolly hats
wrapping the hair a bit more it will dry
out and so
um hydrating products so high water
content products
um or steam treatments are gonna really
help you there
renee i mean you guys have colder
winters than us in new york right so
you know what are you all doing yeah um
so i encourage uh folks to
rethink cleansing as not just meaning
shampoo like you can cleanse with a
co-wash
um to like you know
uh because i feel like shampoo can just
be too stripping for the mid shaft to
end
so interchanging like putting them in
between your shampoos and then also
making sure that you're not sleeping on
anything that's cotton
and then when you're using scarves or
hats or things like that making sure
that your hair is up and it's not
getting traction
in in the scarves because usually people
use warm materials for scarves such as
cotton and wool
which like snap at the hair so wearing
your hair up and away
with that they sell hats now like little
beanies that have satin inside of them
so that you can be really gentle on your
hair
and any like naturally occurring fabrics
such as cotton or
silk they absorb the moisture but satin
is kind of like that money spot
so you're always sleeping with either a
satin wrap or on a satin pillow case
so for all the work that you're putting
in when you're awake to
keep or put moisture in your hair making
sure that you're maintaining that
throughout the night as well
and not depleting that out even while
you sleep because there's just so many
things that can detract from your
moisture just when you walk
outside your door so at all costs like
trying to figure out ways to keep
moisture i hear that i hate and jabelia
can i
i can imagine at this time of the year
your boxes are focused on that
high moisture content high hydration so
tell us a little bit more about that
your take
absolutely i second what both eleanor
and renee
said silk satin pillowcases are my
absolute go-to
i will not compromise on that will not
compromise on my bonnet or my head scarf
but in addition to that something that i
find really useful are leave-in
conditioners and when i was really on in
my hair journey i actually didn't
realize that
leaving conditioners were something that
as black women we actually had those
made for us
and just how valuable they are so for me
in the winter months um with the
exception of today because i've actually
got my hair straightened but when it is
in its natural texture
um moisturizing and sealing every day
even when my hair is straight in fact
i'll just use a little
less leave-in conditioner but adding a
leave-in
conditioner to the ends of my hair and
then following it up with an oil to lock
in the moisture
and then i feel like i'm good to go in
addition to protective styling
so i am your bun queen when it is winter
and when the months are cold because i
want my ends
as renee said off of my shoulders i
don't want it rubbing against my jacket
i want my ends tucked away so and
between protective styling and applying
leave-in conditioners and heavier
butters and oils
to trap in the moisture those are
definitely my go-to's
okay okay but what about people like me
i have a short
you know i think it's called twa like
my ends are not gonna be in a bun or
protected so what do girls like me do
there's things you can do like you can
still apply leave-ins and butters and
twist your hair when you go to sleep
take it out when you wake
up experiment with bantu knots um
head wraps look amazing in winter well
all year round to be honest
protecting your hair with a bonnet
underneath the wrap i think there's
loads of things that you can do
so um we also have um you mentioned
about oils especially
around this time of year um we have a
question about are
are oils any good for moisturizing afro
hair or is leaving conditioner
better i'll stick with you jamila
because you've just spoken about that so
either all or together no not either
um oils don't allow water to penetrate
their hair shaft which i'm sure elena
and renee will speak a bit more on but
oil does not do the job of moisturizing
the hair and i think growing up
as a black woman will often talk like
oil your scalp oil your hair but
that's actually not doing anything so
you definitely need to apply the
leave-in conditioner first
you need to apply the leave-in
conditioner first and then apply the oil
on top to lock in the moisture that the
leave-in conditioner
has just applied and when you're looking
at leave-in conditioners you want
water or yeah water to be the first
ingredient or one of the first
ingredients on the bottle
as well fantastic i mean eleanor
i think we we have had this conversation
before about oils and
and and um more hydrating products
um i i'm gonna hazard a guess
what you'd say but i'm gonna let you say
anyway um
either or or together on top of each
other
so i i would say my personal preference
would be really
more of an emphasis on leave-in
conditioners to be honest just because
if you need to then you can build it up
i think if you're okay with just
applying an
oil over the top and then you don't have
to apply any more products until wash
day
then it's great but i'm applying an
oil layer after you're leaving
conditioner and then maybe the next day
or a day after
needing to top up with another leave-in
conditioner that product then might not
penetrate as well
so if you you know that you're topping
up with your product on a regular basis
in between wash days i would always
stick with like a water-based
leave-in conditioner because you can
apply it and build up that hydration as
and when you need
and it's not necessarily going to be
sitting on top of anything else
that is like uh like he's like um
jamilia said
it's a barrier so it'll hold stuff in
and it won't let stuff
continue in um but but i
i yeah i love i love a leave-in
conditioner i'm a massive fan of the
leave-in conditioners myself
and it is about quality you know oils
are beautiful
when they're incorporated into a
formulation they have um
they show their best value when
incorporated in
i think it's when we sort of like hug
our castor oils and our coconut oils and
assume that they're going to solve
everything
that we can hit a bit of a roadblock
i see i see and renee
what's your give us your take so
i'm i'm like i'm also learning because i
am
a huge oil fan um and
because um but like
not not the way that that's
traditionally used or like
i know that coconut oil got really
popular like 10 years ago and everybody
was putting
coconut oil in and i found that to be
more drying on textured hair than
helpful um and i found olive oil in its
raw's form
was most helpful so i do like that and
the the one thing that i so i don't
really feel like i have anything to add
to eleanor
or jamilia because i feel like i just
learned out of that discussion as well
but
um the one thing that i wanted to say
with at least deep conditioners because
i know hydration is a huge thing and
deep conditioners are going to be on
everyone's shelf
this winter um as they start feeling
drier um is not to
sleep with deep conditioners in because
that's
i know that's a little off topic but
yeah um so people
like they're only so intended to be on
the hair for 20 to 30 minutes at best
um even to go under a little heat or
steam yes but they are
meant to be washed out you are not
supposed to be sleeping with those
because they harden over the hair
they actually make the hair brittle over
time so even the best deep conditioner
should be washed out and then you should
put a leave-in conditioner
in um and yeah i mean i
i always put a leave-in conditioner and
then put my oils on top
but i didn't understand why that worked
best but i
i just learned that here so yeah
fantastic oh well this is what it's for
isn't it it's all first it's the whole
communities jamelia
talks about in the sisterhood it's all
about learning from each other
i mean i was always a big fan of putting
oils on my hair as well until
you know i did the whole and the
leave-in conditioner and
and i think maybe just before wash day i
might put
a bit of an oil because i know i'm about
to wash but throughout the week i'll
just use the leave-in conditioners as
well but yeah i am partial to an oil
hair too
um so i have found with the
the aveda nutra planish deep conditioner
when i mix in their multi-use
oil with that um and leave it on my hair
for 20 minutes and then cleanse and then
go to style
even when i spray the leave-in
conditioner in i get a lot more bounce
and shine from it
um and my hair just feels very supple so
i guess i was wondering like
is that from like a trichologist's
perspective
and like
it would be like a cosmetic scientist
needing to look into the ingredients if
i'm entirely honest
so there might be an emulsifier
emulsifying agent
in the deep conditioner that's working
to sort of
be able to spread and distribute the oil
enough
rather than it kind of sitting in one
big layer when you put it on the hair so
by mixing it in
there's an emulsifying agent in there
already and then it's almost like it's
incorporated
within the formulation so maybe that's
what's happening
i wouldn't be up don't quote me on that
i don't know the ingredients
but that would be my that would be my my
wavelength
of what would be going on well it's all
working together because
it's like i think you alluded to before
if if the oil is in the formula
it works better than if it's just being
on top yeah way better you'll need
emulsifying agents to
spread it out i guess so i guess so so
we have a question
from vk actually so vk sent the question
in saying
what would you recommend for length
retention especially on 4c hair
i think you know i have 4c hair um which
is the tight curls
but you know that's just my layman's
explanation of it it might be a good
idea before we answer that question
to kind of maybe go through the
groupings of hair because i've had
you know i've heard 4c 4b and all that
sort of stuff
how do these classifications come about
and you know what do they mean
so and some of the statistics that were
coming up at the beginning of the
before our show actually started was how
much women
black women spend on their hair and how
little resources they have going to the
salon
to get help with their hair and so
because of that i felt like youtube
exploded because black women didn't know
what to do with their hair when they
started
leaving relaxers and coming into their
natural selves
um and so youtube created this numeric
system that we so commonly use
now but because women were trying to
find themselves on youtube find you
um uh what people like them were using
and then you had these
subgroups one being straight two being
wavy three being curly and four being
coily um and then there are these little
subcategories
in those groups it's literally about
people women black women trying to find
their
their tribe where do they sit and and
that's how it's come about
jamilia do you get a lot of questions
about you know hair typing
and and and people wanting you have to
do you find you have to do a lot of
education around that
yeah we have some really interesting
conversations about this actually
i first came across the hair typing
system um via andre walker who was
oprah's stylist um not too long ago or
at the time
who i'm not sure if he created the
system but i know that he had heavy
involvement in the use and the education
of the hair typing system
but we get a lot of questions from our
subscribers or
women who are part of our community
about which products they should use
based on hair type
and our response is always we can't tell
you what products you use
based on your hair type alone for us the
hair typing system just
isn't sufficient i feel like there's so
much more to hear there's density
there's porosity
there's actually so many other
attributes that determine whether or not
a product works well for you
and i think also the way that you use a
product is also really important
so the fact that all of our subscribers
get the same product and they range from
3a curls to 4c curls um i think it's
just testament to the fact that
you can the way that you use products is
really really important to just how
effective it is
um so for example like someone with 4c
here may want to use a lot more of the
product
versus someone with three a hair who the
product whose hair may be weighed down
by the product
so i think that the hair typing system
is great
for when you're early on in your journey
and you're trying to find people whose
hair looks like yours
but what i found in my own experience is
that it's literally through trial and
error
of finding products trying them and
observing the results that you're able
to see what really works for you
so long story short it's great as like a
guiding system
very early on but i think it's about you
getting to know your hair and
just building a relationship with your
hair because only you will know your
hair
um the way that you do it as you learn
to love it i think you're absolutely
right because
i know that on on my hair alone or my
scalp alone i have different types of
hair textures
so if you're trying to pigeonhole
yourself into i am a 4c
or i am a 3b or i mean i don't even know
if the 3b
exists but you know if you have all
these letters and numbers
and you're trying to pigeonhole yourself
inadvertently
you're restricting what you use and
parts of your head might be getting
benefits and some parts aren't
so for i have been told the majority of
my hair
is messy and i'm like yeah okay
um and if i was trying to grow my hair
which i'm not but if i was trying to
grow my hair
what would i be doing to maintain this
majority 4c
hair to get length eleanor
so for me it would be always about first
of all make sure that scalp's healthy
we've already talked about that
i think we've covered that um then it
would be about making sure your hair is
hydrated
with afro hair the tighter the curl
pattern the more porous it's going to be
and therefore the more likely it is that
it might
endure a bit of breakage compared to
other hair types
um and then it's also about if there is
a little bit of breakage or wear and
tear going on
make sure you get a regular trim and i
think a lot of people see this as quite
counterintuitive
why would i take off hair to keep hair
but i think that if we go through the
like logic
when you don't trim your hair your hair
starts to wear and tear and literally at
the end of it starts to look like that
it sprays open
like a little paint brush and starts to
split down the hair shaft and actually
it starts trimming itself
you're getting a haircut from yourself
but not a very good one
so when you go for a haircut and i would
always say
get a professional trim with someone who
knows what they're doing who can
even out the length as they go um
you are making sure that the end of the
hair shaft is as
neat as possible you've got the tiny
surface area to lose
as little water as possible and if
you've got
great water content in your hair we've
talked already a bit about hydration
then the likelihood of breakage of
brittleness occurring
is going to be less and therefore your
hair is going to last
for longer is that the same talk about
cutting hair then so renee is that the
same
as if you've got longer hair at the top
and shorter hair at the nape is there
any special things you should be
doing for the back to the front or is it
all the same because i've got
you know faded it down you know and
someone
some manny's asking a question you know
she's got force
which is similar to what i've just said
she's got 4c hair that is shorter at the
front
and the nape actually slightly different
hold on so she's got 4c hair that is
shorter at the front and the knee what
can she do to care for the shorter areas
now i'd be like cut the long bits to
shoot to get to the short bits and then
grow together but
i'm not a stylist so renee i would agree
with that
cutting everything kind of in a similar
length if you're just if
things are short because of breakage and
you're holding on to length that's kind
of hanging out around your crown or
or longer it's it i'm
that's not like a look uh i say cut your
hair into a look
a style that you're that you feel happy
and confident with and
when something is cut into a look and it
looks healthier it always looks better
than hair that looks like it's
struggling to
be where it's at so take the confidence
step to go ahead and cut
it so it's all one length um and i just
wanted to echo what eleanor was saying
about the importance of a trim
because i tell my clients that all the
time there are a lot of things that
promise
like the remedy of split ends and it's
just it's not true it seals them down
but it breaks apart and
opens back up and what happens is like
these things continue to go up the hair
shaft so if you're not
regularly trimming these are moving up
your hair shaft and making more damage
as it goes along so you're going to want
to cut those ends so that it's not
continuing to spread and split the hair
shaft right
um um so yeah and then
and thinking about hair in stages um
closer to the scalp
um getting more sebum and things like
that and then the mid shaft to ends like
your ends have been with you for x
amount of years and it's probably been
through a blow dryer too
has been through more environmental
damage and it's just like those things
need to you need to
regularly treat that so your hair can
continue to grow
in a healthy in a healthy place and if
you are
if if your hair is breaking or if it's
short around all of your
this area here then i'm i'm imagining
that the hair that's longer here is not
in a good
position so to to just cut that
and kind of start start over um
and working on like hydrating that yeah
sometimes it's that confidence though to
um to cut it if you sometimes length
this
a comfort blanket and no matter how
short
you know how short around it is but the
fact you've got that little bit of
length might be the comfort that you're
holding on to
you know how we look at our hairs black
women you know our hair is our crown
which it is but it can be a crown in so
many different ways and we can wear it
as a crown in so many different ways so
i guess
that's what it is but talking about you
know you talk about
trimming hair and and eleanor you
mentioned about professionally trimming
hair and renee obviously that's your bag
and all that sort of stuff we've got a
question here
from someone asking what about if you
cannot afford a professional
um regular trim are there any tips
for um cutting hair at home you know
given the climate we are in at the
moment
you know people might want to you know
make some savings in some places so you
know is there any tips with
making a saving of cutting your hair
yourself at home or trimming your hair
at least maybe not cutting into a style
but trimming your hair yourself
so nothing beats going into the salon
because um
like building a shape building a style
um
is uh like no one's gonna do that but
your stylist
but what you what you can do is put your
hair
into twists like like let's say you have
a deep conditioner in there
and you're putting it into twist at the
end of those twists um on afro texture
hair you can feel the knot or you can
feel kind of where it's gotten tangled
or dry
and at the end of those twists go ahead
and give yourself little periodic trims
um and but then when you gain
comfortability with going back into
salon
uh you can you can um have bigger gaps
in between that so i
my usual uh routine is make telling
clients to come in every three to four
months for a trim
but you can create some distance between
those that time period by
doing those little trims yourself but
making sure still to go into
and because nothing's going to replace
that yeah
so you could stretch it to actually
twice a year
you could stretch a professional cut to
twice a year
yeah fantastic okay so um there's a
question we have
about um daily washing
now this is something i struggle with
because i go to the gym
virtually every day and i'm always like
should i erase my hair
should i wash my hair should i use a
conditioner and you know what should i
do because obviously i've got sweat in
my hair and i'm like you know
um just daily washing for afro hair
especially short afro hair it could be
long um
does that is that a problem so actually
if if your scalp needs to be washed
and you can work the kind of like wash
and go looks i'm guessing no one really
wants to do styling
on a daily basis um unless it's wash and
go
then that's absolutely fine what i think
is more important
is about the product that you use to
wash your scalp if it's going to be on a
daily basis
so there are some products out there
that you know really keep their costs
down by basically using
pretty cheap surfactant so the cleansing
agent in them
um and so they they almost do their job
too well you know they cleanse so well
that it almost leaves the hair feeling
and scalp feeling a bit dry
maybe even a little crunchy at times so
if that is happening
i would say either swap the product to a
better quality product
or if you're really needing to like you
say you're sweating you're going to the
gym daily
do a really thorough rinse at least
dissolve the sweat residue off
and then still put a leave-in
conditioner afterwards so that the hair
is still hydrated
and has that conditioning agent going on
it afterwards
but yeah i i i would
really invest in good quality products
if you are cleansing that regularly i
mean invest in good quality
products anyway right if you care about
your hair
but um if it's going to be on a daily
basis yes
you don't want to also cause irritation
to the scalp with
a product that's in contact with it so
regularly
fantastic jamilia i mean you guys
provide
um discovery boxes and i guess this is
something
that i feel like would be in your box
you you would have
the right kind of products for someone
who i can just imagine a
a gym bunny box of of products
someone who's like always at the gym
sweating their hair
you know how how do you go how do you
navigate that
you know because obviously it's a
discovery box but you want people
it you want people to find the things
they need for them
for their particular needs like mine is
you know how do i manage sweat in my
hair all the time
what would you say to that um i would
say
i'll echo what elena said about um
finding the right product but i think it
is very much about experimenting
so there are moisturizing shampoos
there's clarifying shampoos
there's sulfate-free shampoos there's
actually different types of shampoos and
we do feature all of those different
types of shampoos in our boxes
but i think it's then up to you to
choose which one what
works well for you but also rotate
products um
i don't know if renee and eleanor will
disagree with this
um but for me i find it really useful to
just listen to my hair so
if i want to cleanse my hair but i don't
want it to feel strict then i reach for
a certain type of shampoo
or now that my hair is straight and when
i want it to return back to this kinky
curly style
i'm going to use a um clarifying shampoo
which is completely going to strip my
hair of moisture
but it's also going to remove all the
silicones that i had to use in order to
get my hair into
it to stay straight and so i think just
understanding
what the different roles of the
different shampoos are and
thankfully when you subscribe to
treasure chest you do end up with like a
selection of products so you can say
okay
when i use this product my hair felt
like this so i'm going to use this for
today or
do you know what my hair is feeling dry
it's really cold outside
but i've been using a lot of products
and i need to strip these products and
you'll say okay
let me go for this moisturizing shampoo
which cleanses my hair but it doesn't
leave it limp and without any moisture
whatsoever
so i think it's very much about
understanding how your hair responds to
products
and then use those wisely based on the
needs of your hair at that time
it's important to have maybe a a
wardrobe of
products of cleansers i personally have
a walk-in wardrobe
conditioner you know i have a few
options i think people who know me know
i work
i work a lot in skincare and i always
say have a number of different cleanses
for your skin
because there's going to be times of the
month where your skin is oilier you're
going to need a bit more kick
there's going to be times when it's
drier you're going to need more moisture
so i guess you're saying about hair is
the same thing
have a a selection that you may be able
to call it
why not switch it up from time to time
i love that i love that idea we're still
on this hydration thing there's a lot of
questions coming in about hydration
and i guess it might be something to do
with the time of year as well but
for hydration i mean the question is um
and i'm gonna go
i'm gonna stick with you jamilia for
hydration should you wet your hair
before you put in the leave-in
conditioner as then should you put water
on your hair first and then leave in
conditioner or or just leave in
conditioner no i don't think you
need to because as mentioned your
leave-in conditioner should have
water as one of the first ingredients
anyway um i know that for me personally
on wash day i do
apply my leave-in conditioner to wet
hair but then throughout the rest of the
week i just apply it to dry hair
but i think again experiment so i know
that a lot of naturals have a spray
bottle
full of water and you can spray your
hair then apply the leave-in and see how
your hair responds to that
or for example aveda have the
nutri-punish and spray leave-in
conditioner
and it's a water consistency anyway um
so you can just use that instead so i
don't think your hair necessarily needs
to be wet
but if it is already wet because you've
just washed your hair then i don't think
that's a bad thing
so i've been doing it all wrong then
because i will put water on my hair
now you can though i just sort of do
this
and then put the conditioner on i just
think
no one to like dry hair is a bit funny i
don't know
i think i think that's where it very
much depends on your hair because for me
my hair gets really wet quite quickly um
and so when i apply a leave-in
conditioner i can actually feel the
moisture in my hair
whereas if when i was applying a
leave-in conditioner it felt like it was
sitting on top
or it just wasn't working into my hair
then i would wet my hair and apply it
so um there's no black and white which i
think is what we're kind of getting from
this discussion that
yeah everywhere exactly yeah
okay so um over to you eleanor
a question from jude thank you so much
for your question jude
um how do i prevent breakage when my
hair
is in braids what's the best way
to keep hair healthy when in a
protective style
so i'm going to break it down and go
backwards a little bit just for anyone
who might not know what a protective
style is because there's
loads of p there's over 260 people on
this
so what is a protective style renee
and then eleanor i'm going to let you
answer first
about protecting the hair in braids
so a protective style is one in which
where you're not creating
a lot of manipulation to your own hair
so it is in a style where you can leave
your hair alone for a given amount of
time for a certain period of time
that is a protective style um to me my
definition of a protective style is one
where you can access your scalp
because some some people render a
protective style of sew-in
but they don't have they can't even get
to their scalp to itch it or to cleanse
it or
like to even oil it so um to me
that's not a protective style and then
for
any time a client is using protective
styles consistently like let's say they
do a big chop they don't like the way
they
look um when their hair is short and
they want to give it some time before it
gets to a certain length so they're
doing back back braids
um i always suggest that they never do
the same braid
styling back-to-back that it's always a
different
it's different you do cornrows and then
take that out you do box braids you take
that out and you do a different
at just natural hair straight back and
using a lace front wig over that
because the braids do get heavy and
black women in particular
are are prone to traction especially
along the edges
so like switching up the braids if
you're doing it and switching up what
the protective style is but just also
making sure that
like you're not putting something on
your hair where you your scalp can't
breathe or
like just feel the air around it for for
a long period of time
yeah i hear you so eleanor
you know how do we prevent breakage when
hair is in braids
or really perhaps maybe any protective
style i i just i can
feel where this is going but
um all right i think i think for me
personally
we i need to unpack the word protective
style because it gets used once again
in association with braids with weebs
um and for me none of those styles are
particularly protective
for hair they are like like um
renee said they're low manipulation in
the sense that you don't
you know hands aren't in your hair all
the time
but are they protective i wouldn't say
so
you've got tension on the scalp you've
got consistent
rubbing of maybe extension hairs or
things like that on the hair shaft
itself
for sometimes months at a time and those
cause
weaknesses and breakage points itself in
the hair shaft
so by the time you do then take out your
braids you might notice
a fair amount of breakage actually
happening um as a result
so for me the best way to prevent
breakage is to not
have the braids but it's quite a brutal
approach i i totally admit
it's a brutal approach but it is um you
know prevention is a
best form of not having it but
but i think um i think you know what
with all styles there's this kind of
cost of damage that comes with it right
so if you recognize that you want the
braids
um and you also are aware i think this
is what more women
more of us have to be aware of that that
those stars come with this level of
damage
then you can make the decision okay am i
willing to have that damage am i willing
to pay that cost
for the style and if so then well then
fair enough and then
you know once the style comes out like
renee said don't do it back to back
stim your steam your hair really well
condition it really well
probably get a good trim afterwards um
and and
give it a rest before you do another
kind of
long-term style i really i wouldn't
always avoid long-term styles i think
try and leave your hair out as much as
possible but i know it's not always
going to be everyone's choice
and therefore just recognize the damage
cost that comes with it okay so that
said there was a question about
um maintaining the hairline from damage
from braids
which i think is common as stylists you
guys would have seen
that damaged hairline i've got a little
bit of it going on
um and that's from braids so is there
anything
anybody can can do about that
take take the braids out i mean if
but genuinely like if you've noticed
that damage is occurring because of
braids
you can't expect your hair and your
follicles to recover
whilst they're still in braids you know
if you were diabetic
a doctor's not going to say well have a
little bit of sugar it'll be fine
if that's causing you damage so it's
once again i sound brutal because i'm
not allowing some people to enjoy
and still have fun with their styles but
if they are seeing damage
and they don't want that to occur then
they need to stop or change that style
okay i hear you jimin would you go as
far
do you actually let me throw a question
in here do you think as black women we
are too
harsh on our hair we think our hair can
withstand
so much yes absolutely i feel like
the um common perception is that our
hair is really as you said
it's very resistant resilient sorry it
can take a lot of manipulation when in
fact our hair type because it has so
much curvature
in the way that it's constructed is
actually very very fragile
so i feel like our hair cannot actually
take as much as we think it can take
which is why um no low manipulation
styles protective styles have been the
go to for me personally
and it's only once i started doing those
styles i saw a difference in not only
the health of my hair but the length of
my hair
so i definitely think there is this myth
of our hair being
super resilient and um it can take
anything
when in actual fact our hair is actually
very fragile
and needs to be handled with care so
yeah i would absolutely say that there
is
a definite misconception about our hair
type i would renee
the same thing so yeah i would like to
say that
so there's a also a cultural aspect to
this where black women are coming
out of their relaxed styles but also
blow drying a lot because we still see
ourselves for a lot part especially in
the u.s
presentable for work and stuff like that
with our hair straight
as opposed to in its natural set in that
case
when eleanor was talking about
mitigating the chances of risk like
figuring out how much risk
to what like putting a lot of heat in
your hair is more damaging
than box braids in my opinion because
you are damaging
and and damaging inconsistently
throughout your hair um
and with those inconsistent points of
damage like even if you're trimming your
ends regularly if you have this band of
damage somewhere here and your hair is
this long
you have to wait for all of this to grow
out to even to fix that
and as it's growing out it's going to
fray at higher rates and more
is much quicker and so you're never
catching your hair
so heat damage to me is the worst of all
risks
for for black hair very particular and
in that case like
instead of doing that to yourself
especially if you live in places like
the south here that gets really humid
put it in the box braids but then
knowing that box braids or braids have a
certain amount of risk too
right just like playing with those but i
see a lot of value in protective styles
given those things um so i wouldn't i
would never
i i wouldn't say don't because i i just
know
that the box braids are not going
anywhere culturally
it's not happening you know so like
thinking about like
okay why am i using it how frequently am
i using it and then
what are other options i have um so you
used to say that i'm just going to throw
my own question in is there
is there a good way to do box braids or
is that
is it or is there a better way to do
protective styling
um you know should put it like this
should people go to like a stylist like
yourself to do protective styling
because you know everybody has the
auntie
or you know there's somebody down the
road that can braid hair
yeah you know they can pull the front
and all that sort of stuff
and it costs you know so much less than
going to a proper stylist to get it done
is there a right or wrong way to do
protective styling
there are ways to do it better um i
would say
the wrong way would be the products that
you used in order to get the style see
what's really popular right now
are the knotless braids especially in
the one with a bigger base
in which case in order for it to look
neat in the beginning you need to use a
lot of like
gels like ampro and stuff like that in
the hair before you braid it
unfortunately those are very drying and
caustic to the hair
and then you're you're doing that and
you're doing the knotless braids and
unfortunately the knotless braids
so when you put a knot in a braid right
it's like it anchors
in the hair um and puts less weight than
the knotless
braids into the hair
so like when you do the knotless braids
so much of the weight of that extension
goes directly to your hair without like
this anchor first before it comes down
so
i i'm not a like a huge fan of knotless
i like knots still
and then when you do them don't do them
as tight
give yourself some room so like the
really neat finishes with a lot of like
using edge control or like products that
are not great for the hair that's going
to be sitting on your hair as long as
you have this protective style
which generally women would use for six
weeks to two months you know like
these are not um products you would want
to have sitting on your hair that long
um yeah so so basically there is a good
there is there is a good i don't want to
say bad but there's a good and there's a
better way
of if you need to go into protective
styling for any number of reasons which
you know
i think for the sake of practicality of
life you know we're all adulting out
here
sometimes it's just good to just put
your you know hair is the last thing you
want to be thinking about worrying about
all that sort of stuff
so there is some practicality to it um
with the lives we lead so i guess
there's there's a good and there's a
even better way of doing it is making
sure you access that better way
so that you you do protect your natural
hair and you aren't left with nothing
you know you take the braids out and
then you're left with nothing
and talking about being left with
nothing a question which i'm going to
direct
to you first is about
um the menopause because obviously was
it yesterday sunday was national
menopause day
um you know and with menopause there's
lots of internal changes going on in the
body
which does affect skin and scalp and
hair you know so how
how would that be managed in terms of
breakage
changes in your scalp maybe dryer scalp
you know how can all that be managed
i think the first thing to do is is we
all need to talk about menopause more
actually because
as especially for women at some point
we're probably going to go through it
right
in fact we are definitely going to go
through it um but it doesn't get
discussed that much
and like you said deja there are huge
changes happening in the body in terms
of
your hormone levels um which do impact
things that are
dictated by our hormone levels so our
hair growth cycle
is one of those things um higher
estrogen levels will hold
hair or is linked to holding hair in the
growth cycle for longer which is why
during pregnancy we might see hair
you know grow even more or less shedding
occur and then post pregnancy we see a
big
amount of shedding and the same often
happens with women who are going through
the menopause
probably less noticeable if it's quite a
slow transition
through um but you know some women it it
will be over one year and they'll just
go into the menopause within that one
year others it will be over a 10 year
period
but as your estrogen progesterone levels
drop you do
see a drop in hair density your
sebaceous
gland activity may drop down as well so
that's
um sebaceous gland activity is
controlling how much sebum we produce
how much natural scalp oil we produce
and therefore we may see a bit more
dryness on the scalp
um but i think density is probably the
biggest one
and from a lot of my patients who are
discussing that
this it's it's also about just managing
expectations a little bit
you know i don't think it's realistic to
think that we're gonna have
the same density of hair that we had
when we were 18
for the whole of our life that is gonna
change you know and
even if we're in the best shape possible
our body's
internal system is still also aging and
that leads to changes
but i think what is really important is
that if you are going through quite a
like a
more stressful menopause so you're
you're really noticing the symptoms
quite a lot
that you go and get some help to help
manage those symptoms so that they don't
put a further stress on you
you know if you're not sleeping well
then your body's not resting and your
body's in a higher state of stress
and that will impact everything from you
know digestion
to skin and scalp conditions so actually
just managing
the main symptoms can be really really
helpful when it comes to
its impact on the hair and scalp can you
get menopausal hair i know this
question's gonna make me sound stupid
but i'm gonna ask it anyway can you get
menopausal hair
products or products suited
for people more in the menopause is that
the thing
i've i worked with a brand called living
proof
before aveda and living proof
does have a branch that is specific it's
called
something it's um it's difficult to sell
because you're essentially telling women
hey i
can tell that you're
because you are trying to lose your hair
the whole like the
the shampoo preserves coloring because
they uh obviously usually people who are
in the menopause stage color their hair
as well um and then the other styling
products there's like a leave-in and
then
there's a one for plumping like pumping
there because like eleanor said density
is impacted greatly during that time
period um
but that line wasn't necessarily created
with the black woman in mind
um but but yeah i'm i i'll say that like
i do know that there is a brand out
there
that did recognize that this particular
woman in this phase of her life needs a
different set of products or
thinking around product but yeah
chameleon it's an idea right it's an
idea i mean i didn't have an answer for
that because i haven't come across any
in the market
so i had to sit back on that one um but
it's definitely an idea because you will
have very unique needs during that phase
of life so
definitely an idea yeah i like that you
know
you know i i don't think i'm not there
yet but i think that
um if in many years to come that as
black women
um there was a brand out there or or
service out there that catered a lot
more to the kind of changes our hair
because already if i'm in if i'm if i'm
thinking our hair is a little bit more
sensitive anyway because of the
structure and all of that so it may be
impacted more
i'm sure there needs more research and
it may be impacted a little bit more by
menopause so anything in that
sphere would would i guess would work
well but i do have a question for you
jamilia it's a direct question that's
coming in
from manny about the treasure chest
boxes
is there a wait there is
a wait list um fortunately for us
lockdown done really well as a business
so much so that we've reached capacity
for our subscription boxes but we do
have a waitlist in place which we open
up
every month and open a few spaces
and but not to mention on our website we
also have curl care essentials
essentials boxes so these are everything
that i've discussed so a shampoo
a deep conditioner a leave-in and an oil
or a styler
and that will provide you with
everything that you need from all of our
favorite brands and it's only 25 pounds
so while you can't subscribe you can buy
as frequently as you please
these curl care essentials boxes which
will continue to introduce you to new
brands and new products
you know whilst obviously i'm sad for
people that there is a waiting list
i am also very happy for you as a black
business owner and brand
that you are in that position and i hope
that you up
you will you will recover from it and
obviously let more people in but i think
that's fantastic so congratulations and
well done you
um so we've only got we've only got a
few minutes left and
what would be great to hear from each of
you is
um about it's about moisturizing black
hair so
lots of questions we've had tonight
about moisturizing black hair keeping
um afro hair hydrated so it can you know
be in its best health can you give us
some
your sort of two key i'd say two key
product recommendations
for moisturizing black hair i'll start
with you jimmy this thing since i was
just talking to you just now
as in specific products or product types
specific products um for me
the aveda nutriplenish deep conditioner
is a dream i love the smell of it um
i'm very naughty though and i do sleep
with deep conditioner in my hair
but i do sleep with a shower cap on so
it doesn't dry
on my hair and it is still moist in the
morning mainly because i'm shattered by
the time i've completed the shampoo
stage of my hair
so by the time i apply deep conditioner
i'm ready to sleep and so i would
definitely say aveda as far as a deep
conditioner
and then as far as a leave-in
this is the leave-in that i spent years
trying to find
and then once i found it it works it
doesn't work as well for my hair anymore
but i did at the time
and that would be giovanni's deep
moisture leave-in conditioner
fantastic eleanor if i can get two from
you please uk
hair recommendations okay um i'm
actually hopeless because
i we make our own products right so i
haven't used any other brand in the last
10 years
um so uh our leave-in conditioner what
can i say
it's lovely um and we use it on all our
hair types and it's hypoallergenic
so that's the one i know about and i
feel secure to recommend
but i would say maybe just a tip rather
than a product recommendation
is if you are looking to try and lock in
a bit more moisture when you're adding
your
leave-in conditioner try some single
twists
or some two-strand twist once you've
done your leave-in conditioner
and it will just clump the hair together
and hold in more moisture rather than it
drying out straight away
so you'll benefit from a bit more
moisture so yeah
our leave-in conditioner and twists
fantastic thank you
renee last but not least what would be
your two
um hair moisturizing products for
for black hair um jamilia i just wanted
to say that we have
uh under the nutraplenish line i got to
make sure i remember to have them send
you a sample because it's in the kitchen
still it hasn't come out on the shelves
yet but
the nutraplenish deep leave-in
conditioner it's much
it's heavier than the spray leave-in but
it's it's better to keep on your hair if
you're going to exceed the 30 minute
time frame
um with it on your hair so just look out
for that
um but for me the
spray leave-in conditioner like jamilia
said because every time you spray it in
your hair
um it is a water base it it promises 72
hours of
hydra hydration so it's like it boosts
hydration and it keeps
all the things that detract the
hydration from your hair like just like
when you walk outside
from happening um so it keeps all of
those things at bay
um and then for me making sure
that your styling products are natural
i know that this is not a specific um
but
um it's like a tip making sure that the
thing that you're using for styling
are naturally based products um so like
you're looking for products that
are at least 85 or more naturally
derived than
not um because like everything else
things that are
like silicone heavy like real moisture
really can't get in there and penetrate
so if you're looking for maximum
moisture
and things are going to be sitting on
your hair for a certain an x amount of
time
days um making sure that it's naturally
direct
fantastic well i can't say how pleased i
am we've had this session
thank you so much we have run over a
little bit so
i just want to say thank you to everyone
who stuck in and listened in
and and i could see the chat going and
lots of interesting conversation
happening in the chat
not less a conversation that we're
having here as well so thank you so much
and for all your wonderful questions as
well
renee ellen or jamilia it's been an
absolute pleasure
um and i have learned so much as well
and
and i'm sure everyone else has as well
thank you for sharing your knowledge
thank you for sharing your evening with
us um
if anyone else is sticking around for
the sessions to come then if there
anything to go by if this is anything to
go by then
it's going to be live so um thank you
thank you so much i can't say thank you
enough thank you everybody
thank you thank you i'm gonna sign out
of this now see you on the next one